Planeswalkers are crap in EDH. This
seems to be a common belief and yeah,
it's reasonable cuz planeswalkers are
hype in other formats, but when it
carries over to multiplayer, people
realize they're pretty overrated. And
for some reason, they're not printing
multiplayer-oriented walkers. I mean,
these abilities can easily be a minus
two or a plus one, but why are they not
making planeswalkers that are strong for
multiplayer like they do for sagas? Let
me know what you think. But at this
point, we've reached the other end of
the spectrum, I feel, where people are
just neglecting the walkers when they
deck build. Yeah, they get beat up as
soon as they come down usually, and
they're so complex now, I can't even
remember which one does what. Yeah, I
feel like when people build decks,
there's like a mental shortcut where
they remember certain iconic cards. But
for most people, I feel that shortcut
for planeswalkers is just ignoring them.
So today, I'll do the work for you. I
went through over 300 legal
planeswalkers for Commander to find
eight that can be quite good and very
underrated in the format. Now, this is
more than just a list, but hopefully
will give you some insight on how to
evaluate planeswalkers and consider
which ones are suitable for which decks.
So, let's begin. We start with pretty
decent choices, but end with walkers
that I generally believe are bombs that
people are neglecting. Starting with
Nahiri, the Unforgiving. One of the
biggest traps for evaluating
planeswalkers is looking at their ults
like at all. This is one of the massive
reasons why people will do what they can
to take them out. But then, there are
bombs like our Nahiri over here. What do
you mean working hard and depleting my
loyalty? Best I can do is zero.
Minimum wage, minimum effort vibes here.
But because of that, just like the OG
Garruk, your opponent sometimes will
just look at her and leave her be. And
honestly, that's a very relevant hidden
upside for planeswalkers in Commander.
Now, let's look at her abilities.
Usually, I treat planeswalkers like they
are spells, so I evaluate based on what
I can do immediately after dropping
them. For Nahiri, the most relevant one
here is zero. Now, the equipment part is
a bit of a trap. Why would you want to
reanimate an equipment for one turn and
then you have to pay the equip cost? No.
But getting a creature back is actually
super relevant. You can bring back a
three drop or a five drop, give it
haste, and you know, get all the ETB,
get to attack, and that seems really
good. The flexibility here is also
excellent. Being able to cast her for
three mana means that if the coast is
clear, you can drop her early and get
some value with the plus one. Just keep
looting, and eventually animate
something big. I don't think she's great
in equipment decks, but she fits really
well in the new Lorehold strategies that
cares about graveyard and creatures.
I imagine she can be quite good in decks
like Jared and ones that work with
graveyard like Dahada and Selvala. Might
be surprisingly decent. All right, next
up. Now, I know I said the alt is a
trap, but I'm a man of constantly
lowering standards, especially for
Nissa. Nissa, Vital Force has a special
place in my heart because I've seen her
alt more than almost any other
planeswalker. Because she comes down,
makes a sizable blocker, and if you time
it right, she can alt almost reliably.
And in a land stack, this alt will win
you the game. But beyond land stack,
just any Simic value deck, any deck that
ramps a lot, or decks that are a bit
short on card draw like my Rafiq Mikky
deck, especially if it can control the
board, can make good use of this
planeswalker. Now, the minus three
ability is not great. You can use it in
a pinch, but but to get a permanent back
to your hand for five mana, because once
you minus three, you have to plus one,
and the plus one is not super useful for
the most part. I don't think it's a
great deal. So, I would only play Nissa
if you want a high-risk, high-reward
kind of card. I mean, the reward is
huge, so I would definitely try this in
some of my decks. Next up, Ob Nixilis,
the Adversary. Now, this is one of the
most unique planeswalkers ever printed,
and is actually quite difficult to
evaluate cuz it can make copies of
itself, and then you can activate it
twice. And yeah, what exactly is this?
But I think for this card, I have a very
specific home. It's decks that can alt
Ob Nixilis immediately. Yeah, decks that
can reliably make large creatures, decks
like Greven, Ozai, or even Sorin. In
these decks without green, Ob Nixilis is
almost like a Momentous Fall with lots
of upside. I mean, you're left with two
planeswalkers ticking up, ticking down,
making devils, just being annoying in
general. Or even if your commander is
just a power, take a look. A mix list
might also be a decent fit. And next up
we have Dack Fayden, Shadow Slayer.
Yeah, they managed to make a
planeswalker that scales with the game.
This is a nice design, but they had to
be really careful with the abilities.
But they're still pretty decent. So by
turn three this becomes a removal, not
amazing, but serviceable. And it gets to
straight up reanimate an artifact later
on in the game, and that's usually when
you need this effect. And surprisingly,
we don't actually have that many
refurbish effects in magic. So if your
deck wants it, this is a solid choice.
So yeah, you either get a removal or a
cost cheating reanimation. And often
times Dack Fayden can even stick around
for some surveilling, or at least absorb
some damage. This is a solid choice for
pretty much any deck that involves
artifacts, like Urza or Sharuum.
According to EDHREC, he's only in 10% of
Sharuum decks. I think this number
should be higher. Next up is Jeska,
Thrice Reborn. A lot of people are
distracted by it being able to be a
commander, and also maybe entering with
very few counters, but again, this is
not a planeswalker. See this as a
sorcery three mana give target creature
triple strike. How many of those are in
magic?
Zero. Okay, I guess something like seize
the day is close, but look at how much
mana this costs. Seven. Meanwhile, Jeska
allows you to just boom someone out of
nowhere. I mean, if your commander has
red and has seven power, this is just an
alternative kill condition. Even if
beating people up isn't your plan A.
Imagine Jeska with the Titanic. Holy.
And another sweet use is in decks like
Slicer or Elaxious, because the damage
tripling effect lasts until your next
turn. So yeah, double strike people
might see coming, but triple strike,
let's just say I die to it a lot. And
apologies for the sudden voice change.
Um, I I didn't finish recording
yesterday, and today I woke up with a
cold.
So, I mean, what else am I going to do?
I I'm not going to work. So, I guess the
top three will sound a bit different.
Yeah, and they are special, and these
are some sweet planeswalkers. Some of my
favorites, alongside Ugin, of course.
Number three, we have Teferi, Master of
Time. Now, this one's probably not a
surprise. It's really strong, and it's
got this multiplayer oriented mechanic.
But again, 1.5% of decks, I don't think
that's a good indication of how strong
this card is. Now, this is a card that
can actually snowball in multiplayer. I
think a lot of people are
misunderstanding this one, expecting it
to protect itself with the minus three
ability, but that's not reliable enough.
However, if your deck has some kind of
control elements, is able to support
Teferi with, say, removals or even just
solid blockers, this can cause a lot of
headache for your opponents. I guess
there's some discussion about the
ultimate is taking two extra turns, so
bracket four, but I mean, it's a
planeswalker ultimate. I feel like a lot
of the ultimates of planeswalkers would
be game winning, even more than this
one. So, I do think planeswalker
ultimates should be treated a bit
differently in this discussion. But,
personally, when I play Teferi, I just
alternate between the plus one and minus
three most of the time, and it's more
than enough value for four mana. And
number two, people know about this card,
but it's still criminally underplayed.
It is the Eternal Wanderer. It is one of
my personal favorites. I just do think
tragic arrogance type board wipes should
be used more. Only the ones where you
get to choose, and this is the case with
the Eternal Wanderer. So, again, this is
a planeswalker that is kind of close to
a sorcery, the minus four ability. Now,
I understand why they kind of avoid
doing this, I guess for identity issues,
but when they do, these walkers are the
ones that are most playable, I find. In
this case, paying six mana is a little
bit expensive for this effect, but as
long as you're in the right deck, the
Eternal Wanderer will most likely stick
around and generate value. I mean, the
token is also one of the best tokens a
planeswalker can possibly make. Now,
like Teferi, the decks she can go into
is a bit narrower, but any deck with a
powerful, dominant commander can
consider this. Especially ETP decks or
Voltron decks that can synergize with
her top two abilities. And finally, we
have number one, and it's been my top
planeswalker choice ever since its
release 10 years ago, Dack Fayden. Dack,
20,000 decks. Worn Powerstone, 200,000
decks. Now, I know there's a color
limitation thing, but that's more like a
reminder that you should be playing it
anyway. But, yeah, look at these two
cards. Squint.
They are basically the same card. Dack
Fayden has one job, to steal Sol Rings.
All of them. And dropping this on turn
three against someone with a Sol Ring
start is just brutal. And of course
there's the slim possibility that nobody
has a Sol Ring by turn three. And when
that happens, nobody has a head start,
you can just drop Dack Fayden and get
value. Three mana planeswalkers are
excellent if they can scale with the
game and Dack Fayden absolutely can.
Most boards will have plenty of
artifacts to steal. And that's what I
think a playable planeswalker should be
in Commander. It's nothing flashy, no
broken ultimate, but just something with
a solid ability to serve as the floor
situation and lots of potential upsides.
Okay, and that's all of my picks. I'm
sure I've missed some. Which
planeswalkers are surprisingly good in
your deck? Please let me know. And also
check out my affiliate link Kakapopo TCG
for excellent, excellent, accessories.
And if you do, use my discount code
levels, all caps.
And I'll see you in the next video.